good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
thursday we are back in studio we have
an hour of silence for you
and we are ready to hit you with the
fast five with deer toasters with real
housewives recap so
get [ __ ] ready get [ __ ] ready we
have so much silence we can't wait to
bask in it also today is a very special
day it's the first time ever for me
but not for you i i think i have done
this when i was on the breath
but i don't think i've done it on the
toast okay first time ever for me
not wearing makeup on the show i got a
facial yesterday and i just want my skin
to breathe and it just didn't make sense
for me to wear makeup today so
and i stand in solidarity with you i
appreciate it so much it definitely like
takes the pressure off
of course you know and my makeup was
like packed so it was like annoying you
know when you're going somewhere but
like your makeup you need to do makeup
like it's so annoying
so actually like i was happy to do it
yeah no i feel really good about the
choice also we're recording extra early
this morning so
just nobody needs makeup that early in
the morning i completely agree and like
i had a hectic morning you know my
fridge was leaking it was like a whole
drama
yeah no i've been like packing all
morning just busy busy busy
yesterday was like the busiest day of my
life like meetings meetings meetings
meetings meetings meetings like
pre-pandemia
levels of busy like not a moment to
myself like not a moment to even snack
pre-pandemitria lovato levels
it was it was craziness like it was nice
to be busy
but i literally didn't have even a
moment until like six o'clock to watch
the vlog that we posted yesterday well
that's what i did it all day like
uh upload and edited the vlog it was
literally a joy to re-watch that footage
it was
so funny and i actually ended up like
looking better than i remembered
you looked so cute every outfit was like
kind of fire no i know
like and we were just being like hard on
you well no you were being harder
i was so funny trying to be so
supportive yeah no you really were and i
definitely felt like you know i was
taking out some of my
you know toxicity on you and for that i
do apologize oh thank you
that's so appreciated just getting
dressed on camera like is never not
stressful
no it was actually reminding me watching
it was reminding me of your
dress when you were like i hate
everything about it i'm like
she's the same [ __ ] no i'm literally
the same person just like longer hair
yeah a hundred percent um a new chin oh
new chin and less moles i've gotten a
couple holes removed since then and more
filler and lit
well if you want to watch this iconic
vlog that people are saying is like
their favorite vlog of all time which is
just always nice to hear
patreon.com the morning toast and then
and then oh yeah last night the vlogging
never stopped because i went over to
olivia's axe
and finally filmed their home tour so it
is done it is in the can we've got
kayla's room just this oasis of pink
pink
taylor and that will be up this weekend
so
it's a great time to become a patron
it's never too late to become a patreon
and i think a lot of people think that
it is just because like we've been going
for so many years now
but you know what a lot of people don't
know is that when you sign up for
patreon
you get all the old episodes so if
you're ever like needing 200 episodes to
watch
head over to patreon.com slash morning
toast don't get it twisted it's
slash the morning toast but i will say
that you want to
you want to sign up like now because
sometimes like old episodes for one
reason
or another have to go by the way said
like members say yes to the dress
episode like if you were a patron that
month you saw that episode
but if you joined after it was already
taken down for licensing it was
copyrighted and it's not going back up
we can't if you want to watch it now you
just never know where where the
licensing is going to come from
so if you want to watch these vlogs now
head over to patreon.com
morning toast yeah i don't think you'll
regret it no i haven't heard of a
regret me neither so um we have a great
show yesterday we made the decision
because we were podcasting from home due
to some of the local law 11 construction
happening outside our uh
studio we decided to postpone deer
toasters because it's so much better
when we get to do it in person and just
like vibe
and soak up each other's awesomeness so
we're doing that at the end of the show
today we're also recapping last night's
finale of jersey
and new episode of beverly hills which i
watched this morning and i have many a
thought on
so we just like are so busy like we are
busy and then like from here it's just
like meetings meetings meetings
meetings catching flights not feelings i
mean
this could be this actually be crazy
like if i say this and then like it'll
haunt your
you know memory forever like this could
be the last time you see me
because i'm flying on a seaplane to the
hamptons
which tpg says they're safe and i'm also
flying with tpg which i just feel like
he has like cpr and no not that like the
universe would never like let a plane go
down that tpg was on and he meant
he changed his flight and i was like i
have to do whatever you're doing because
i'm not taking the one that goes down
like i'm going on your plane
yeah so we'll see if i show up next week
but who knows this could be the last
time you see me
and this is how you'll be remembered
yeah no makeup [ __ ]
um okay like that's just a lot of crazy
stuff to put out there
i just feel like if i say it it can't
happen you know i don't know i could
just see us re-watching this episode on
the news channel right after my funeral
well okay let's see in case i do perish
i would like to say a few words okay i
to my family
just know that i love you more than life
itself and i probably wasn't scared like
really i was probably fine
two like you were fine no i wasn't fine
but like i was probably like
you know drunk for sure second thing i
would like to
say is that i've really loved my time
here at the morning toast and i don't
know who you're gonna replace me with
but i have a few criteria one she cannot
be chubbier than me
okay two she cannot be funnier than me
okay three
extra points if she's related to us like
it probably would be snitch or
yeah um and four like just know whoever
takes this seat like i
will haunt you like till the end of time
um
and i've just really uh the ghost of
claudia's past passed
across here there are a few if this
message gets heard there are a few
select toasters
who i will spend my afterlife literally
hunting and ruining your life
i know you all by name and i will
literally make it my mission in heaven
yes that's right i'm going to heaven
you i don't know i will make it my
mission to ruin your life
and i love you guys and have a great
life
um okay claude i think that like should
something happen i think
my strategy for replacing you i think i
would turn it into a patreon series like
america's next top morning toast that's
a great [ __ ] idea you know
and i would do like sample episodes with
people and i have one more stipulation
i'd like to add
and i will be reincarnated and i'm
coming back as a nurse named ashley
jessica rn
that's beautiful that's beautiful love
you guys
um well i hope that you know everything
goes your way this weekend
and that you have a great weekend on top
of that we do
you know it's it's so exciting that it's
memorial day weekend like it
it's the start of summer summer summer
this is literally us right now like
we're watching the clock summer summer
like literally summer starts this
weekend it's gonna like summer's about
to pop off you guys
i mean i don't know if we're ready if
we're if we're ready i think that we are
you know i've been trying
my best to get ready like my absolute
best so i think i'm as ready as i'll
ever be
i'm feeling a little overwhelmed like
it's opening weekend of the summer the
hamptons is gonna be like so
i like have social anxiety like i'm just
i'm not myself anymore at parties you
know and it's going to be overwhelming
she's so shy no but it is supposed to
rain which i kind of
won't be mad at cause then like
everything will just be like kind of
mellow but like if plans
go like according to plan like i'm just
gonna be like on the cover of hampton's
magazine
we'd love to see it yeah i think it's
about time i think it's about time
also yeah um yeah no i i worry for your
shyness and your
social anxiety it's not that i'm shy
it's just like
i really don't know how to function at
parties anymore like i really just keep
to myself not in a shy way but just in
like a
do i have to talk to you kind of way
yeah but you know what everybody's
feeling that way
i know so you're not alone that makes me
feel better are not
alone you are not alone
did you see ben platt perform on the
voice finale no i did not it was
absolutely stunning i don't his new song
imagine is fine i don't think i like it
it's it's
a bop but it's not like i have higher
expectations for him
and it was kind of just like very you
know we are never getting back together
like you know
like you know how taylor her singles
aren't always like the most best
best but they're very pop yeah that's
what i feel about imagine but he gave
an unbelievable performance like his
singing his dancing that he was really
good
speaking of unbelievable performances
someone posted in toast after our katy
perry performed on american idol like
with the with a finalist thinking of you
thinking of you which is one of her most
amazing songs that's so underrated and
she [ __ ] crushed it she does really
well on american idol she also
you will love this performance she did
part of me like a stripped down version
with this girl katie who was on like a
season
maybe like two seasons ago um it is
literally
the most gorgeous performance and the
girl katie's really good too and they're
harmonizing
and they make it such like a different
song but it's beautiful like you will
love it
wow okay i'm gonna i'm gonna check that
out yeah even though i'm such a busy day
i don't know when i would or i could
she also looked gorgeous in that
performance i love her as a blonde
but just that song is so good and she
and she really crushed the performance
so thank you to
whomever posted it yeah um i feel like
we should dive in like we are so
we have so much to do today on this
episode we have so much to do
to do um he's at his grip where are you
he's
grandparents oh we'd love to see that
okay without further ado did it do
though
um let's get into the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode of morning toast is
brought to you by babel for most of us
learning a second language in high
school or college wasn't exactly a high
point in our academic careers
very very true but now thanks to babel
the number one selling language learning
app there's an addictively fun and easy
way to learn a new language
whether you'll be traveling abroad
connecting in a deeper way with family
or you just have some free time babel
teaches bite-sized languages
by babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world
so they offer a ton of different
languages i feel like honestly
if you're living in america and you
don't speak spanish like you're at a
disadvantage
and it's a really good thing to know
a language to know how to speak and if
you really feel like picking something
up in your free time i highly recommend
babel
they have 15 minute lessons that make it
the perfect way to learn language on the
go
they design their courses with practical
real world conversations in mind
and it's things you'll get to use and
say in everyday life other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 100 language experts
their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages
some of the ones they offer are spanish
french italian and german the italian
camper is
quaking she's always brushing up on her
italian and i heard ac is taking italian
so that she can bond with italian candy
that would be very kind they could
bury the hatchet between them babel's
speech recognition technology helps you
improve your pronunciation
and accent so you don't like you're not
that guy you know john
start your new language learning journey
today with babble and right now when you
purchase a three-month
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
so that's six months for the price of
three just go to babel.com and use the
promo code
tmt that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code tmt for an extra three months free
babble
language for life love it babble always
reminds me of that lady gaga song do you
know it like no
it's called babylon like oh babylon
it's a very rue very art poppy it's from
the new album
oh like it's very like vogue they should
license the song
in their commercials oh also they
announced the drag race all-stars
um cast like people are like super upset
but like ginger minch is coming back and
so is eureka who i've really felt like
was a stunning queen
so i don't know why people are upset but
like it'll be good it's exciting
like i'm just excited to have drag race
back on like whatever like i don't i'm
not i'm not here for the backlash
when i usually am okay first story
newlywed ariana grande shares photos
from intimate at home wedding to dalton
gomez on may 15
2021. she's going to be ariana gomez her
initials don't have to change
her initials don't have to change but
like she would never sorry
ariana grande sharing sweet photos from
her intimate wedding to dalton gomez
earlier this month she shared the photos
of her and
him kissing during the intimate ceremony
in montecito california
as she wore a sleek custom white dress
by vera wang and he sported a suit by
tom ford
according to vogue which covered the
wedding grande walked down the aisle
accompanied by her parents
joan grande and ed butera which makes
you think of when
i walk down holding hands with my mama
and i'll be thanking my dad cause she
grew from the drama
only yeah um i didn't what i mean she
only wants to do it once real bad she's
gonna make this [ __ ] last when i
interpreted that song i just imagined
only her mom would be walking down i
know we're down the aisle but i'm glad
that there seems to be some sort of
represent
yeah she was holding hands with her mom
and thanking her dad at the same time it
was very sweet
her look was very simple her hair was up
but in a more bridalized
moment the look is everything like of
course she wasn't wearing thigh high
boots and like a sweatshirt white dress
um but she still looks like ari but like
very much bridal ari i love
this sleek white dress she just looks so
teeny tiny like a
little cupcake yeah no by the way you're
right she still looks like ari like and
she has a very
unique sense of style that honestly like
sometimes is not very imaginative like
it's very repetitive
um but i like the name broke don't fix
it all right and you're supposed to look
like yourself on your wedding day and i
feel like she did just that that veil
like bow thing was
so elegant and different adorable
adorable like a tiny little
teacup like so cute so um it was really
beautiful like hashtag stunning like
seriously
stunning i can't get over the pictures i
love everything about it i think she'll
be inspiring brides
for a long time to come i think this
might be one of my favorite bridal
celebrity looks like top 10 of all time
and it's so
simple you know and that's just
beautiful and elegant it's not for
everyone but it's
it was stunning yeah no it's it's truly
stunning i'm glad she shared photos it's
nice i like how she went about
everything
yes she took her time i'm sure she
enjoyed her wedding it was just for her
and now she's letting the fans in on it
which we deserve
yeah of course but like what does pete
davidson think
oh it could have been him and honestly
like joking it doesn't
not look like pete davidson that's true
like she obviously has a type yeah this
would have been great if it were pete i
know like that was that's really like
the only thing that could have made it
like better
but again happy for the happy couple so
happy for the happy couple and you know
ari she made her choice like
i just can't get over that she got
married no i know i just felt like
and i really like i believe her when she
says in that song like she only wanted
to wants to do it once real bad so like
this must be the real thing
yeah right i mean time will tell
obviously time will tell it's
so so stunning okay next story some news
that i never thought like
i didn't think about it much but when i
did if i were to think about it i
wouldn't think that i would be reading
that kim kardashian did a q a on
instagram oh
my god okay when i saw her post the
prompt like i have the time today i was
shook i was so
shocked because first of all like what
is she girls no job like only
losers do that first of all second of
all it was very clear that she
had done this q a with some intention um
to clear up a few rumors and i wouldn't
be surprised if she
asked herself some of these questions
because i'm not gonna lie like
i have done that as well oh well i just
don't know how you go through the
millions of questions she must have been
asked and i'm sure they were all about
kanye
no yeah no but there are some lingering
questions there's a lawsuit going on
basically saying that kim hasn't paid um
her like gardening company that like
does the landscape at her home and she
cleared up the rumor and honestly i
completely believed her it's that it's
not her problem
she paid the vendor it's now she paid
the like the management company the
management company did not pay this
vendor and that's wrong and the
management company should be sued but
kim has already paid
yeah so it just sucks like she gets
attached and then also
this travis parker travis barker someone
asked did you hook up with travis barker
and she said no
false narrative we've been friends for
years and i'm so happy for him in court
and you know what that's that on that
yeah kim shutting things down
i kind of love this like direct approach
yeah so many rumors always about the
kardashians
um and i just kind of love this method
of
communicating with us yeah also she let
us know that she did not pass the bar
uh and two things to say
one i did say that i would just like
some credit
credit because i'm always wrong like
when you and i very very rarely do we
argue but when we do like i'm always
wrong and i'm just like making a case
just to like make a case
but i was right about that and also i
think it's time for a follow-up to a
little disagreement we had a few weeks
ago
about olivia rodrigo being a one-hit
wonder i think
so i think her album is so good there's
so many other bops people are loving it
it's too soon to say no no too soon
only time will tell deja vu was a hit
good for you as a hit no but like
a one hit wonder means you have one hit
no claude talk to me
seriously in like four years no because
let's say she's irrelevant in four years
let's say no
let's say she's irrelevant in four years
like falls off the face of the earth
she still is not a one-hit wonder she
had multiple songs hit the charts
go viral play on the radio people are
obsessed with like therefore
she is no longer she's impossibly a
one-hit wonder so did carly rae jepsen
no she didn't she has so many songs even
on her debut album
no yes like what i'm gonna go to her her
spotify
literally if you can't remember them
like are they hits uh yeah
um i really like you 361 million streams
on spotify
okay go to hold on
because i i'm right i don't think it's
too soon to tell at all
it's too soon to tell it's all about how
you're remembered that's what a one-hit
wonder is about and it's too soon you
know
what i wonder if someone with one song
no it's not billy ray cyrus had album's
worth of songs
[Music]
by the way billy rates hold on jillian
says
dylan's on google billy ray cyrus had
many top hits
but he's a one-hit wonder he's actually
a three-hit wonder but olivia's just
like
she's not a one-hit wonder like you
can't say that anymore it's
too soon to tell the jury's not out and
they will not be back
for years the what the jury no
you think you're not like it's just all
about the cannon
you know but it's also about the hits
and she's proven hits
and she's not a one-hit wonder it's
about how they remember you
and they'll remember me as being right
about this i hope you're right but
only time will tell if you are sour's so
good
yeah are you listening to it i've
listened to the first half of it
oh you seem trepidatious um well it is
really good i like how it's like a
paramore vibe
yeah you know um what i was expecting
bringing back that mood which like
makes me want to you know work out snap
your neck and and snap my neck
for sure it's just um it's really
surprising that she has so much material
from like this one relationship
yeah this 12 year old boy he's a big
loser like no i know and it's like
she's obvious like you write from
experience so it's like this is like
she's so young this is like the one
boyfriend she's ever had it does feel
like overload at some point like
we get it like you feel betrayed but the
music is really good and it slaps so
like
just knowing the back story like it's
just a lot of the same
story the same thing yeah yeah yeah
completely agree but she's also so
limited in her experience like
a hundred percent what are her boyfriend
she's only like 17 like 100
um but it's it's very good like i'm
enjoying
except there's a i've been hearing it
everywhere and like i enjoy when it
comes on
okay so you know when like you hear a
song and you think of what the lyric
like should have been and it bothers you
i'm having that with the song traitor
because it goes like this
yeah you talk to her when we were
together
guess you didn't cheat but you're still
a traitor
and i feel like it should be yeah you
didn't cheat
but you're still a traitor to me
like the to me like it just feels so
obvious
because also the line before is cheats
like cheat and me like kind like not
hardcore rhyme but they bounce off each
other it's just like i sing it like to
me like it bothers me
so much interesting yeah i think i'm
like onto something
yeah you should go on songland just like
what is
coming back i don't know i was just
thinking about songland it's so good i'm
always thinking about ryan tedder and
like how i can become his girlfriend
yeah let me know how that goes we've got
so many hoops to jump through first i
gotta start with ben
and then find out how to get to ryan um
i really miss songland
me too and it's just like so good even
though the one thing i don't like about
a show like songland is
it's so centered on who the
guest is that if i don't really like
know or like the guests like i just
don't watch the episode and that's true
then it's like i'm limited in the
episodes i can watch
that's true no but i think if you were
like dying from our songland you could
watch those episodes and you would still
like them but i agree like sometimes i'm
like oh i'm not gonna watch that one but
i also really like it because they do
like lean heavy into country like lady a
was on florida georgia line like they
they do it all yeah they do it all enjoy
okay ready for our next story
sure well i'm not okay i'm ready
kelly clarkson will take over ellen
degeneres's daytime slot and
claudia was right again news the kelly
clarkson show has been so rare
you know has been tapped to take over
the slot currently occupied by ellen
when the latter show comes to an end
next year clarkson show which is owned
and produced by
nbc syndication arm will take over the
slot in fall
2022 on nbc owned stations
yeah i mean obviously like i'm happy to
be right but it was really not like a
hard prediction to make like what else
is on tv right now that's successful in
daytime
yeah but you know not that it was a hard
prediction to make but like
there's so many slots in the day so like
the odds that like really kelly would
take ellen's and that like nbc is saying
like
kelly is the next ellen yeah it's a huge
honor it's a it's an honor it's a big
move
and do you feel like this just kind of
makes sense in the universe like i feel
like for a while like
we've always loved and appreciated kelly
clarkson but she's had like highs and
lows in her career
and i feel like for a while and i think
she talked about this on watch rapping's
live
like she really just like didn't fit in
and like she didn't she doesn't like
hang out with celebrities and i felt
like for
for a while she was kind of
misunderstood and i feel like she's like
found her place in this world
as as it comes to like entertainment and
like her job and i feel like this is
like now like all is
what will be right with the world yeah
no definitely as a kelly stan it's like
no one is seeing what you're seeing and
not really so it's frustrating you're
just like screaming into a void
and so for her to have this sort of
success like this is
you know top tier success like turning
being a celebrity and turning that into
a daytime talk show host is like
creme de la creme that means cream oh so
that just reminded me when we were
catching up on kardashians how they they
referred to chris's failed talk show
and chris actually gave some interesting
insights she said it wasn't a failed
talk show like i was only ever gonna do
it for a year i was taking someone
else's time slot for a show that got
cancelled don't know if that's true
but that does make sense because the
more i think about like the wonders of
the world the more i
wonder like why the chris show like
really didn't take off well i would just
say like i'm sure
it was meant to be a year but i'm sure
also if it was really good and everybody
loved it it would have continued
on but you think it was like a little
too early maybe
maybe but like maybe like chris is so
many things and like everybody's
obsessed with her and loves her but
maybe she's just not that warm talk show
host energy
no it's very specific chris and the
girls i don't want to hear about
whatever guest is here
hundred percent you know that's the
thing when you're like a funny
person people always their go-to was
like you should have a talk show
but it's like actually part of a talk
show like 90 of the time is just
listening to other boring ass people so
interesting people
not that kelly clarkson isn't
interesting you know what i mean like
when you're like such a big personality
you actually
don't deserve a talk show because it's
not about you yeah
i would say boring i would say the same
like unless you're wendy williams
no yes that's true but like wendy
williams talk show is literally
not about anything other than wendy and
like she's a guest she's like so many
segments including the guest segments
and she was like known more for
her hot topics than her yeah guest
segments yeah she's always like rude to
her guests
i actually was just watching like last
week she got into a fight with a guest
the guest called her out she's like
i don't know who it was she was like you
just like don't support women like
you're always coming for people
and i actually think she made some valid
points what did she say no she was just
like
she was getting lost in the nitty gritty
she's like when i come to your show you
don't give me flowers it's like okay
that's not what we're here for
but she says like in her hot topics and
in like some of her interviews she's
like always kind of
like bringing women down and what one
decide in response
she was just like trying to move on with
the interview like literally ignoring
this girl's
kind of you know fair points
interesting it was a very funny video
well so happy for kelly clarkson um
can we just let us know when we can get
back to vegas
like we're still waiting on that reason
so that's the other thing
here it's like what does this mean for
the music of course we get kelly oaky
but when you're so busy daytime talk
shows every single day every single day
where does the music come in when is she
hitting the studio when is she touring
how do you tour
i mean i guess you have seasons so like
in the off season but she's a mom like
it's just a lot it's a lot and i just i
want what's best for kelly do you think
this means she's like somewhat retiring
from music
no because like i think the music pours
out of her she couldn't retire she's so
musical
you know like truly okay next story i
found
so interesting is it the you know keep
going um
yeah might as well since you've already
is it
is it the next story that's brought to
you by quince it is
that's fabulous do you like luxury
products
i know you do i really really do do you
love the quality of designer clothes but
you don't like the price
yes then you will love quinn's what does
what do these items truly cost to make
like that you're purchasing so marked oh
my god
hundreds percent more yeah so now it's
more affordable at quince
if you love luxury products they don't
have to be that expensive they're marked
up eight to ten times by retailers
but quints will connect you directly
with the factories that that make the
products for the world's leading luxury
brands so you get the highest quality
products at an insanely
low price you'll find the finest apparel
cash
accessories and more at 50 to 80 less
than what you'd pay for the same quality
as the most expensive luxury brand
products
they have products like washable silk
loungewear pajamas italian leather bags
100 grade a mongolian cashmere sweaters
and sets
literally anything you can think of it's
a shock like when you go on their
website it's just
quality quality quality at very very
reasonable prices especially compared to
what they're marked up at at fancy
department stores
their goods are incredibly high quality
they're made in a sustainable way and
they're sold at
radically lower prices it is 100 factory
direct
there's no retailer markups or middlemen
you can compare quinn's products with
any premium brands
you'll see why their customers at quince
are rated so
highly every quinn's product is
guaranteed to meet or exceed the quality
standards of leading luxury brands and
if you're not completely satisfied
they'll give you a full
refund and there's free shippings and
returns for 365 days that's a year
for free shipping and returns to get 50
to 80 off the top line clothing
and home goods plus free shipping text
tmt to 6400
that's tmt to six four zero zero zero
terms apply available at one quince dot
com
terms text tmt to six four zero zero
zero love that okay our next story
very interesting jason tardik and dean
unglert
reveal how much money they were offered
for her bachelor in paradise
this is so interesting on the first
episode of jason's podcast trading
secrets they did which i
um i recorded an episode i don't know
when it's coming out but
the pair discussed how much money they
were each offered to appear on bachelor
paradise back in the day
so dean shared the first time he went on
he said quote they hit me up and they're
like hey do you want to do bachelor in
paradise this other show
it pays 400 bucks a day and you could be
there for up to 30 days or something
like that so dean was like yeah great
400 bucks a day 30 days 12 000
that's fantastic and then he started
talking to some of his friends and
they're like well you should get more
money because you're who they want most
from your season
minus peter krause because he was like
caught up in all this drama like he was
with christina like dating in the off
season
no but yes yes but and he also did the
final
originally he was just on rachel season
and people loved him yes but even after
rachel season like he was caught like a
coachella like hanging out with
different girls like
he was linked so he was like an
interesting thing he was an interesting
figure
and second only to peter krause wait
like 400
a day is not a lot it doesn't sound like
a lot but if you are there for 30 days
12k
like that's a pretty good page but most
people aren't there from start to finish
first of all and second of all
i actually don't think it's enough money
for a tv star like who's literally being
exploited in every way possible yes but
then dean said he then asked for eight
hundred dollars a day
before producers countered offered with
600 he said which was fine with him it
could have been one dollar more
just out of principle i wanted them to
pay me more than they were offering
everybody else
just because i thought i was hot [ __ ] or
something yeah then he went on to do
bachelor winner games which he got four
hundred dollars a day for
and then interesting that they pay
people per day like i just didn't think
that
yeah no i didn't think that either he
also said that after the first time
bachelor in paradise with danielle and
christina
yeah and they he was coming back again
he said he wanted twenty thousand
dollars an episode of course for some
absurd amount um but then they
settled on like six hundred and two
dollars oh my god that's so
funny i mean i guess for dean like he
looks back on that experience positively
because he met kaelin
yeah but i i feel like a lot of people
don't have like the best time on
paradise like it's like they like set
you up to like embarrass you a lot of
the times
and on i don't know what amount of money
is worth that yeah and also now that you
think about it like people always cry
when they go home because like i always
thought it that as like loss of
instagram followers
like money if you're getting paid per
day
400 snatched and i guess that makes
honestly i never thought about it but i
guess it also makes sense like it gives
people incentive
to want to stay longer to be
manipulative just to get a rose
not to fall in love to have another week
to fall in love but have another week to
sit here and earn 400 a day yes exactly
so what did jason say
so then jason explained how when he got
a contract for bachelor in paradise once
in 2018 but he was never on was he no
yeah
but he made a contract for 600 a day
with a 5 000
guarantee in case he didn't make it past
the first week smarter he opted not well
he's a businessman like that's the kind
of deal he makes no 100 and then jason
and dean also discuss their offers to
become the potential bachelor
jason said that when he was in the
running with fellow contestants blake
and colton
they were all offered a hundred thousand
dollars for the season
and then dean said that he had a
contract back in the day to be the
bachelor but it went to ari and he was
offered 75 000. yeah they say
that the bachelor salary is
intended to be one full salary one full
year salary of whatever that person's
job is
so i think there's like an urban legend
that andy dorfman had been paid at one
time
the most because she was a lawyer and
then i guess that would have meant like
rachel lindsay also would have been
paid that high but now i feel like it's
literally like it's a hundred thousand
like yeah i think it's pretty standard
and
i mean on the one hand that sounds like
a lot for probably
60 days work but on the other hand like
they are carrying this show that
generates so
much money a hundred thousand dollars to
bachelor producers is a fart like it's
nothing
yeah but also i think it depends on like
who knew that dean had gotten a contract
it depends on the person i think a lot
of people are
somewhat interchangeable but there's a
certain season where it's undeniably
like
emily maynard probably made a million
dollars because like it couldn't have
been anyone but emily like no one was
interested in any other person
and they wanted her so bad she was an
amazing bachelorette
so they probably paid her more like if i
had to guess really but it was also back
in the day so with inflation she
probably was paid back in the day
with inflation probably like a nickel
which today
would be you know a million dollars
totally
so anyways i just thought that was
interesting well that is actually the
premise of jason's whole show like when
i did it he was like we're just gonna be
really open about like money and like
sales and like that's like my
uh like worst nightmare yeah because
like it's nobody's business like how
much money i make
but um i did my best yeah no i on the
one hand it's like yes people should be
more transparent
because also it helps everybody grow
with the economy like when you see what
other people are getting and you realize
your own worth
on the other hand it's tacky to talk
about money yeah no and it's also just
like super uncomfortable
but like this article like with tea and
everything like there's not anything
tacky about this no because these are
offers that they didn't take except for
like the one dean did but
yeah but like i just i don't know it's
different
yeah i agree it's different it's
different when you're offered money from
a network versus when like you built
your own business
kind of yeah no it's just different i
can't explain it how it's like not
talking about money like it's just like
spitting packs yeah
spitting facts are you ready for our
fifth and final story it's the final
story
[Music]
okay it's always hard like to stop i
know but it's once you get started you
don't want to stop but the listeners are
like please stop
fifth and final story instagram and
hiding likes
the solution is here we are so messy
starting today all instagram users can
omit likes and views from displaying on
their own image and video posts
and if you really want a fully likes
free experience the app now lets you
hide
the likes and view counters on all posts
in your timeline
so as you know and i was like oh i guess
it finally started oh interesting yeah
it's here i guess they figured out a
solution to like help people with
mental health but i actually think this
makes it worse because it's like not
everyone's going to hide their likes
no of course then it just like creates
this like stigma almost
but there actually is another update
within instagram that i think is
actually way better um when
when you when you block someone now you
can also block
all future accounts they make because
like you know people love to like
talk [ __ ] to you and then you block them
and then they'll literally make a fake
account just like start
[ __ ] talking you again and now instagram
has developed some sort of technology
where they know if it's like from the
same person the same phone the same user
um they will block all future accounts
which i just
love it's so beautiful but it's a little
too late considering it doesn't
block all past accounts oh it doesn't no
damn yeah it's just a little too
late a little too long and i can't wait
um okay well those were the final
stories and
i think you needed to know them yeah
well we still have so much show to do
let's talk real housewives in new jersey
tv recap
real houses in new jersey part two and
final part which was kind of weird
because
it wasn't really like a terribly boring
season no but i'm good on re i'm
i'm we did last night but it was a
boring reunion like first of all
i feel like there was a lot missing
i feel we didn't make any resolution or
even an attempted resolution between
margaret and jennifer
and i feel like we didn't even
eventually get to the meat of it like
just they kept going after each other
and andy never like started the
conversation so
i felt very unfinished
but i do think we actually got to a
decent place with theresa and jackie
and even though it was like cringy at
the end to watch teresa like kiss ass
theresa is only nice to jackie when
evan's around like
no it's so crazy the way she talks to
him like oh
evan i'm sorry if i ever heard your
family you know like batting her eyes
and then to jackie like saying the most
vile violence she's awful like
she's so awful like the fact that she
couldn't see her own hypocrisy with the
kim d
analogy it was the perfect thing to say
like kim do you accused your husband of
cheating based on nothing and you went
ballistic
she said she didn't go ballistic and
that jackie actually went crazier
what are you talking about like that's a
that's just untrue like
and people try and call her out it's so
frustrating i don't know how
when joe gorka was sitting there like
literally about to [ __ ] his pants when
andy asked do you think your sister is
wrong
and he eventually came and said yes but
like that
that clip is just indicative of
what a monster teresa is and how
hypocritical she is and honestly
i have never had more respect for
melissa gorga than i do in this moment
because even if you don't like her or
you don't agree with her like
you have to have sympathy for her like
she has to operate in a friend
social group on tv with her crazy
[ __ ] sister-in-law
who never defends her but the second
melissa like stands quiet for two
seconds
teresa goes back to flipping tables like
i honestly
don't know how melissa hasn't lost her
mind yet
yeah she must love joe so much yeah to
put up with that
i i agree but also i don't know what we
i guess
if joe had said like teresa like
straight up theresa you are so wrong
like
that's the only person who can get
through to teresa and it would have
meant something so that's why it even
matters for joe to say anything and i
wish he would be a little like
heavy more heavy-handed with teresa yeah
she actually like is in love with him so
theresa listens to him yes for the most
part no she does and that's what we
learned this season like
it's just i found it to be so
infuriating i think jackie did a really
good job of
standing up for herself and trying to
make teresa see but like theresa just
is like i it's it's
impossible to talk to her it's not
having a real conversation like
she doesn't
logic or deductive thinking like i just
or comparative i can't
yeah no it's like there's there's no
sense in making a good argument because
it doesn't matter like it does not get
through to her
yeah so like we're all just you know
talking to each other and it's just not
penetrating
and then like for like the fact that
evan went over and like was so nice to
her after and like
i just literally was evan's a better
image than i could ever be
a hundred percent but like she's like i
was thinking let me play skal
no but when when she was like you know i
really never meant to hurt your family
or anything like but like you did and
that's literally what you tried to do
no and then she'll literally just turn
around to jackie and be like a
completely different person it's like
so weird she's obsessed with evan she's
obsessed there's such a shift in her
demeanor the second he comes out
she was being vicious to jackie like
right before the husbands came out
and the second he comes out she's like
she's aminable
you know we should play golf you know
you're right i shouldn't have said that
like
oh and she said something that like
pissed me off so much she was like i
mean i did apologize to you and like for
me like i don't apologize like you
should be grateful like are you [ __ ]
kidding me like who do you think you are
the queen of england like yeah
even the queen of england apologizes
like you're not totally we've seen the
crown
like you're not so special like she was
just like no she really thinks this is
her show
for her to come down to like a new cast
members level and apologize is like
like we should all just be grateful yeah
it was just bothersome but honestly it
was i felt like a weirdly
unfinished reunion no by the end with
the pineapple juice and like
when louie came out i found myself
smiling and i was like
stop smiling also let's talk about
teresa saying she would
never let a man in tip like theresa that
conversation was horrible
like when when jackie was saying like
they used to come and massage her
shoulders at like the law firm
and she was like you let them do that
like theresa
what like that was horrible teresa and
jennifer when it comes to
talking about sexual assault like it's
actually offensive like they're they're
so dumb like
it was it was bothering me so much and
it was bothering everyone but again
there's nothing you can say that will
make them
understand especially theresa so
everyone's just like
okay even andy like is trying but he
also goes about it like he's so harsh on
somehow
yes when it's unwarranted yeah and it's
so like
um monique monique but then also like
like put like kids handling theresa when
it's like no she
like i think andy is also someone that
teresa probably listens to and like yeah
if he were a little bit
more firm with her maybe we could make
some progress 100
and he should have been more firm with
her with the sexual assault stuff
because that was just like out of line
yeah you let them like what yeah
um but i mean it was fine honestly like
it's so tough for me with jennifer
because like i think her behavior is
abhorrent
but then like when bill comes out i just
like love him and like he loves her so
like
maybe i'm not seeing something yes and i
want to say on the
the rumor joe benigno front what i
really do think happened
he heard it in the house they came home
from the party the next day they were
talking about the rumor
and then he didn't know that like that's
where it originated and he was like yeah
i heard her in my house
i think that that's really what happened
i completely agree and i'm not just
being like a margo
margaret apologist even though like i am
admittedly like a margaret apologist
like i absolutely love her and she like
never looks better than she did at this
reunion yeah no
that's really what i think happened
other nothing else makes sense
yeah um and then beverly hills which was
just
so stunning and delight it was such a
delight first of all
i enjoyed and i never never ever enjoyed
like a new housewives like backstory
i enjoyed crystal's home life so much
first of all
her housekeeper is so funny when she
said that
her brother is like a huge pop star in
china
and he's a nanny at her house like i was
crying she just has a very interesting
life her husband is so successful and
that scene where she brings him
breakfast and he's like i'm in a big
meeting and she's like i'm sorry and i
feel like a lot of husbands like
would have like ushered her out or like
maybe like like yelled at her like
he was just like no it's fine like he's
just like i was very surprised she comes
with a [ __ ] camera crew while he's
like
actually busy producing a movie and he's
like honey it's fine i'm like oh my god
i love him like yeah
it was just so interesting her her fam
her house is so nice like that
estate with the garden in the backyard
like it was just stunning i really
enjoyed getting to know her and i
usually
hate it i agree i enjoyed getting to
know her like i'm i appreciate the
backstory want more can't wait for more
of her personal life scenes also her
interview look with like the three bows
stunning stunning
she's just like really like an elegant
queen but she's also kind of [ __ ]
which i really enjoy
yeah um and then we have this sit down
with kyle and garcelle and i have to say
i think that it is should it should be
referenced it was such a productive
conversation
i felt like garcelle really got to say
her piece and it's clear that it's been
bothering because whatever what happened
between kyle and garcelle was like
not that serious but barcelona's been
hanging on to it and i didn't understand
why and i felt like she expressed
herself very well
and kyle received it i don't think
kyle's
calling her out on the charity thing was
at all had bad intentions
or she only said it because garcelle was
black but i think garcelle is extremely
valid in her feelings and kyle did not
get offended like how could you say that
kyle handed it well garcelle handled it
perfectly and i feel like they really
put it to bed
i did and then when they were in tahoe i
really felt like they
have like the air they have a clear path
to friendship
whereas like rena is the problem like i
love
garcelle calling out reyna literally
garcia
literally you threw your best friend of
20 years
under a bus in front of literally the
entire world why the [ __ ]
would i want to be your friend it's such
a valid simple question
such a valid question when they were
sitting on the bed and like lisa rinna
will just say
everything jump how high to move on from
this and start her next season of being
a housewife one she worked
so hard for and she's like really you
want to take me back there like she'll
say anything to to make it go away and
then
and when they were done talking and
lauren was like yay like and garcelle's
like
no no it was so cringy like i [ __ ]
love garcelle for that reason like
she hates like serena and like honestly
watching this group of women
the there are sun people and lisa rin is
one of them this group is like so
fabulous right now
that are getting left behind lisa arena
is not as fabulous as the other women
just in terms of her
demeanor her style and her personality
like she's just kind of like
like tacky with her hair and her leopard
dress like
it's just all so like old and i see this
new woman i see kathy hilton i'm like
why is cathy hilton on a plane with this
summer now like when lisa randall was
like cheersing on the plane she was just
being like so loud and annoying like
well i feel like
the way i see rena is like but she's
kind of like a social lubricant
like she will make sure the group like
she's always she wakes up and like
charges and it's like yeah like like
she's [ __ ] kelly ripoff
yeah yeah so like these women like don't
have to like i just feel like her
role in a group of friends is like
energizer bunny we're bringing the party
yeah
we're dancing we're you know she works
like she does not stop yeah and it dries
her butter
so that's i don't i think she she's
going hard on she goes hard on that you
know
andy's baby shower like she's always
gonna turn every party up
because not everyone can be kathy hilton
or crystal or erica jane everybody has
their thing
and rinna's thing is like you want her
at your party it's gonna be a fun time
i guess like i just i feel like the need
for rinna is getting less and less every
season
yeah i just feel like if they're on a
boat or something you know
someone's got to be the one pouring the
shots playing the music and dancing
kyle does that like they all really turn
up yeah kyle is really like
the perfect housewife like i know and i
only came to that conclusion a few years
ago
first of all she's so social outside of
the show she's constantly raising the
bar for the show she brought kathy in
chris jenner was on the show
with with uh kyle like kyle is
constantly raising the bar for all the
other women and she's evolved with every
group like
she was the taylor armstrong like but
and now she's the to read and you know
they just posted on instagram rena kyle
dorit erica and teddy mellencamp are
like five best friends they're like this
unit they call themselves like the
fierce five or whatever
and like kyle is really like at the
center of it so kyle's in
like what she brings to the show is it's
incalculable honestly
and with the kathy hilton at all even
though i feel like i literally don't
know kathy hilton at all after two
episodes like she did like
but she has a fan like that was funny
but like i just don't know where i know
and i feel like we're expected to know
her like these weird quirks about kathy
like i'm like
but who's kathy no but next episode it
looks like garcelle like kind of comes
for paris which
i guess like it's different because like
paris is like this larger than life
character but it is someone's daughter
and like
literally the mother is sitting right in
front of you it feels very inappropriate
we'll see how we'll see how it pans out
i feel like it could have just been too
sliced edited where they're just sharing
a funny story
yeah um and then the episode ended like
very bizarrely like i feel like sutton
was really drunk
yeah because like i was not following
her logic
i wasn't following anything about the
conversation and was making me feel like
the way that they cut him they edited it
it's like just show us the conversation
as it happened as opposed to like
there's these moments of like silence
and they're just showing everybody's
faces and then it got like really heated
very quick and i'm like wait how do we
get here like becca
i i mean maybe it really just went that
sideways that fast but i really feel
like it was a really weird editing job
where it's like
they just jumped into this heated
conversation
and just based on the way they were just
showing different camera angles i was
like
i think that this is just like a weird
compilation of footage
yeah because like sudden going on this
rant about her seeing rednecks on tv and
how she's stereotyped it's like
no person who is alive in 2021 would
bring that up
like in a conversation about like race
well she did
at some point i just feel like the from
point a to point b
like there was no linear yeah it just
wasn't linear and like kyle was just
like
it's really how chaotic it was and yeah
so it's easy was crystal drinking i feel
like she wasn't but she was making
drinks for everyone
uh i wasn't i wasn't monitoring her
drinking the house i did look it up to
see if like we could go
we we can't afford it um but
17 bedrooms 8 000 a night i looked up on
airbnb
this morning oh my god well i mean 17
bedrooms i was going to say like no one
had to sleep on the ground floor because
of the bears thinking the same thing
but they probably have like cast and
crew but they stay in the house the cats
and girls
i feel like they probably did for this
like they probably did like a covered
bubble in the house oh for sure kobed
yeah
yeah yeah it looked like a fabulous trip
amazing and like with the plane and
everything they were just so cute two
truths didn't a lie when erica was like
i wore a wire in a government case and
then she said
oh i can't tell you which is the truth i
feel like a lot of people were like she
wore a wire around tom
i think it's too early for that first of
all and second of all i think that she
was saying she can't
she can't say on on tv her lie because
she did work for the mafia like uh
do you know what i mean oh i think like
it was taking people on twitter were
like shook like she said she wore
a wire for tom you know yeah yeah but i
don't think that that was what it was
two truths and lie was funny it was a
good way to get
to know everybody's personality kathy
hilton giving three truths yeah i know
you just like got to know people
yeah it was interesting i agree um so it
was a good episode
it was really good i mean even a bad
episode of beverly hills is so
sickeningly stunningly fabulous even
though that plane was kind of beneath
them
100 like a passenger plane like give us
the locks give us the glam it's an hour
flight it's not like a 20 minute flight
yeah give us the glam yeah it could have
been better um all right let's dive into
your toasters now which is our advice
segment and it is brought to you by
the zebra think about all the
quarantined purchases you made
love sex for some of us um then there's
one of your biggest purchases of this
year
insurance americans overspend on car and
home insurance by the billions every
year
that's money that could have been spent
on more retail therapy more investments
for you jackie
and that's where the zebra can help the
zebra is the nation's leading insurance
comparison site for car and home
insurance
in minutes you can compare policies from
every major provider for free
all on one independent marketplace after
a few questions the zebra pairs people
with the right insurance company for
them
helping everyone save time and money you
can buy online or over the phone with
one of their licensed insurance agents
make sure your make sure you make
insurance your smartest
purchase yet i'm sorry make insurance
your smartest purchase yet
visit the zebra.com toast that's the
toast love it all right dear toasters is
our advice segment if you ever want to
write in we're actually doing a very
special deer toaster segment in a few
weeks so please write us your quandaries
we need your
best and your brightest your best all
right dear toasters at gmail.com first
up
jackson claude i'm not even going to
take the time to address how i'm an avid
listener
or how much i enjoy you both because i
just have to cut to the chase i've been
with my boyfriend for three years and we
will be moving in together in the coming
weeks
he is a true pee job i've never had
trust issues with him we haven't had any
major rough patches
until now he was out with his friends
and they were all going to a strip club
he said that he would order an uber home
and although he didn't have any interest
in going to the strip club he also
wasn't ready to cut his night short
he said he was totally he said he was
totally okay and he understood if i was
uncomfortable with it but he wanted to
ask my thoughts
i gave my blessing because i didn't
think it was a big deal he has my full
trust and i knew he would hate the strip
club so i figured i'd let him find that
out for himself
wow we love a confident queen anyway a
few days later he confesses that he
bought a lap dance of course
i can't even look at him without wanting
to throw up i view it as
as completely disgusting and cannot
fathom why he would want to do that
he admitted it felt wrong and gross and
has apologized he has answered every
question i have asked and has been very
patient
but i just want to punch him in the face
i feel like my trust in him has been
diminished she feels so out of character
do i even know him anymore now the big
question am i being irrational how do i
forgive how do we move on
help attorneys you still know him yeah i
don't know
like a gray area yeah no i think strip
clubs are totally fine i think lap
dances yeah it is
a gray area he did tell you first of all
so i think you need to
focus on the positive he told you he was
going and then was happening
right so that's good i have to try and
put myself in this situation because
for you i want to be like lap dancers
aren't cheating like they make the world
go round like
yeah they got to make the money but if
my husband
came home and told me that he got a lap
dance
i would be pretty peeved i think really
i'm like very
protect like i think like literally ben
texting his female co-worker like
is cheating but i said peeved yeah no
but i don't know something about a strip
club like i just like lit it's like not
that deep like
literally like no offense ben but like
she's danced on a lot of people's laps
like you're not special no sh you're not
special like she doesn't want you
no like not at all she probably thought
you were weird she smelled like you were
just one in a million
yeah so i don't know there's something
about a stripe club that like
i don't know i say that and then it but
i know i actually really don't think i
would care
yeah it's so like unemotional no i would
i would definitely care i would get over
it but i would use like
while i'm being upset about it i would
use that to my advantage like whatever
i'm wanting
whether it's a material item or a foot
rub or just you know some concession on
like a decision we have to make i would
be like well you
got a laptop but you know she is mad
about it so like maybe let's
like we can't make her unmad like she's
bad no these things take time
but i would just say like while you're
in the stage of being mad and your
husband wants to make boyfriend
your boyfriend wants to appease you you
know might as well get some things out
of it
yeah this next one's really long hey
claudia and jackie from across the pond
to british toaster needs your words of
wisdom
i've recently found out that i'm
pregnant for the first time and i'm due
early 2022.
it was completely unplanned and
unexpected but me and my boyfriend of
three years harry are overjoyed
whilst this should be the happiest time
in my life there's one thing that is
casting a major stormy cloud over
everything my older sister who was also
pregnant
i'm supposed to be hosting an
extravagant baby shower for my sister
catherine
at my own expense in a couple of months
but now i don't think if i should i
don't know if i should pull the plug and
say do it do it yourself
she's due in two months and hasn't
spoken to me since i told her my news
and thinks i only got pregnant to steal
her thunder oh my god some people have
so much time on their hands
when i told her she didn't even say
congratulations or hug me she just said
things like it's a shame
it's just a shame for you both i'm also
pretty certain she's been telling
various
family members my news which is really
upsetting as i'll never even get the
chance to tell my grandparents that i'm
pregnant for the first time ever again
to give you some context she's 33 and
already has a 10 year old she got
pregnant with this baby on a first date
with a guy called william
they are now kind of together she has
always expected our family myself
included to fund her life for her rather
for her rather than work rather than her
work i've personally already bought her
so many things for this baby like a car
seat a changing bag and paid towards
many of the bigger items for her
i'm in my late 20s in a long-term
relationship and both me and harry have
well-paying jobs in a house
i will not need to need to nor would
want to
have anyone buy me things to have a baby
it has now been two weeks since she has
spoken to me and i know she said to my
mom that she isn't even going to think
about processing my news until she's
given birth as she needs to focus on her
own baby
she's also bumped into my boyfriend
harry and refused to even acknowledge it
having my big sister give me advice and
share her wisdom would have been so
great and i'm so upset and confused that
she is seeing this
as anything other than happy news we all
know she is annoyed that the attention
isn't on her now it's not like she
invented a vaccine she got pregnant on a
one-night stand it's hardly
groundbreaking
wow what would you do would you still
host a shower or say no you can do it
yourself now
side note she's a big crier even in
non-pregnant time so confrontation is
really hard
thanks so much from a toasty mom to be
well first of all mazel tov on your
pregnancy i feel like
your positive news has been completely
overshadowed
and honestly it's tough because with
family i always say it's
her sister or sister-in-law sister okay
with family like i always say like you
have to make it work like
family is family but at some point
someone becomes so irrational that like
there's literally it's like a teresa
judas moment like there's nothing you
can do and honestly like
this is your life too like you're
pregnant also like honestly like
i think you need to like seriously like
step back like she's
sounds so toxic yes exactly so what i
would do is
i would i would have a conversation with
her give her one last chance and sit her
down and be like
listen i'm about to be done with you
list off the things that you told us
like who even says like
how is anyone getting pregnant like any
sort of has anything to do with you
have anything to do with you so be like
i'm about to be out
i don't want to plan your shower you are
not deserving you are such a [ __ ]
ingrate
yeah and love the word and great i
really at this point like don't want
much to do with you i have no intention
of buying you more gifts and
you you know being a part of your life
you being part of mine
yeah like i don't know what i gained
from this relationship you can't even be
happy for me when i'm
pregnant like good day sir
give her a chance maybe see herself
and be like no i would love to you know
do this together and and you could plan
her shower but i would try one last sit
down
where you spell it out for her just like
you did for us because when you say it
that way like
only a teresa couldn't see yeah but it
does seem like you know you guys have
let her get away with this type of
behavior so she's never been like
challenged on it she's just kind of like
spoiled in that sense
so i just think your communication like
write down your thoughts and you've got
it down
you could be like especially as now i'm
starting my own family like i don't have
time to carry
you and your daddy so
this is an inflection point for us as a
family do you want to be
family or do you want to be taken care
of all the time and held your hand like
a baby even though you're the older
sister no and you're right like now i
feel like it's been whatever
while you have just been like a kid but
now like you have your own family to
worry about
and that's your priority like the safety
and just like mental well-being
and she seems so toxic that like it's
very sad
you're you're right like she should get
another chance but you need to really
spell it out for her like what's been
going on and like how
you're four feet from the cliff like
you're about to jump off yeah and the
shower goes with that but it's not even
about the shower no i know but like i
think the
the sister is like fixated on the shower
no i think that
this shower is like this inflection
it's a it's just a you know the point
to which there's no turning back yes of
course it's like the the mountain
yeah all right here's our final one
ready jackie claudia and crunchy angel
dora
before should we still read it yes i
must tell you both how much i love you
girls and how you have impacted my life
from the show i love you guys so much
thank you okay here i go at the
beginning of 2020 i got out of a
four-year relationship very shortly
after that i had started talking to
someone i work with right before coven
let's call him tim we started hanging
out all the time and for the first
couple of months we were quarantined
together and spending every second
together
given that tim and i both worked for a
nightclub we were completely out of work
our club was shut down for months so him
and i were just pretty much chilling
um all the time in my apartment at first
it was awesome we were obsessed with
each other he's a total pgm and very
open to wanting to be in a serious
relationship
even though i felt that tim was a was
complete marriage material i was unsure
at the time about jumping into another
serious relationship
even though i really liked him i
panicked and felt like everything was
going too fast
i pulled back and expressed that i
wanted to do my own thing i was still
very communicative that i saw
a future with him tim was crushed but
still respected my decision i knew i was
hurting him but i wanted to be fair to
myself
and him to not rush into something that
i knew would be super real if i wasn't
completely ready
fast forward to a year tim and i still
flirt with each other at work all the
time and there's definitely still
something there on both sides
i have a lot of love in my heart for
this man and i know the connection is
real i just found out he left a couple
days ago to film a reality tv about
finding love
one that he and i watched together i
was completely blindsided i feel like i
got hit by a bus the bachelor right it
has to be
or you know love is blind too hot to
handle there are so many these days he
didn't tell me he married at first sight
right he didn't tell me he was going to
do this he just left without even
telling me
i know he doesn't owe me anything
because i was the one who ended it but i
just can't help but be crushed
there's a big part of me that thinks
he's my person for life and just the
timing wasn't right
there's so much i wish i could say now
that he's potentially going to find the
love of his life
did i [ __ ] everything up do i go to try
and contact the producers
and stop tim from continuing off on the
show what if they make me be on the show
i'm not looking to be on tv
i keep trying to tell myself that
whatever is meant to happen will happen
and it'll work itself out no matter what
ever since i found out that he left for
the show my stomach has just been a
week-long
pit i'm freaking out and don't know if i
should chase after him or not i just
wish i could have one more conversa oh
here's the show ready i just wish i
could have one more conversation with
tim before he commits
should i let things be or chase this
dude down on live television
the show is love is blind oh
by the way i can't wait to watch a
season and find out who it is
wow i can't wait to watch okay listen no
love is blind is like this actual like
incubation experiment yeah yeah you're
not penetrating the producers they're
putting you on
sorry oh that but it's not one of those
trash shows like are you the one where
like nobody gets married
like this is a real matchmaking system
we have two couples from last season no
but also there are so many people that
like it
that go on the show the odds that he
even like ends up
meeting someone getting engaged and then
going on to that phase are very slim and
honestly if that does happen for him
like you've got to trust the process
but also possible no it's not impossible
but the odds are slim
the odds are slim and they're not
interested like there were so many
people on love his blind last season who
we never even
met and so they're not showing one of
those people's girlfriend coming in so
don't no you can't get on the show
you've got to wait but you know what
like have faith
that if tim is your person he won't
connect with someone like he's connected
with you he's obviously going to compare
every conversation to everyone that he's
had with you
if he has a better connection with
someone else like that's something that
you need to know maybe you just want him
because you can't have him anymore right
or maybe
absence makes the heart grow fonder and
now you realize what he has on the
minute he comes home from the show
unmarried you guys will be together you
have to wait and see what happens
crazy running into the studio banging on
the door looking for nick lachey like
that's not how that particular show
works right if this were the bachelor
like you could maybe do that and they
would put you on the show
i just think also you were the one to
pull back from tim and like it's not
fair that you take away this chance from
your team to go on the show and maybe
really find
true love because like it's so the show
is serious so
now it's tim's time to do what tim wants
to do but tim really does sound like a
catch like
he's so into like relationships like he
no not
in love with you now you know and if tim
comes home with another
married then you can write in again and
we could we could see about how you
could go about that
yeah but if tim comes home single
there's a path for you yeah maybe he
needs to you know if you love something
let them
set them free and if they come back
nobody else wanted him
exactly no you've got to let him do his
thing because but you also have to keep
us updated on this because i'm like
dying to know
no i'm dying to know if he does get
engaged you can email us like privately
you just want to know when they watch
the new season like which one was tim
yeah
literally same and also actually he'll
be the one who worked in nightlife
no i know by the way it like it won't be
hard at all to figure it out
yay um okay also if you've written this
in the last couple weeks and we have
read your prompt on air please provide
us with an update we want to know if our
advice was helpful what happened did
anyone get married
dear toasters gmail.com for all your
quandaries and your updates
that's our show no one else's let's get
into this
long weekend enjoy it acknowledge the
space we're in we will never have this
much weekend in front of us
we are back in studio on wednesday you
guys know jackie has to go away for a
wedding so she will be back
in new york on tuesday and we will be
back on wednesday
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast have a great safe
weekend
have fun
kd what would norma kamali do you have
so much fun it's the beginning of summer
summer summer summer turn up
summer summer summer love you guys have
an amazing day thank you so much for
listening to the morning shows monday
morning show we live without surviving
morning bye bye